this next story it's not so much
mathematically complicated but it can be
confusing if I don't explain it
correctly so I'm really gonna try to do
a good job here as many of you know
every member of the House of
Representatives represents roughly the
same number of people there are 435
districts in the United States 435
representatives for those districts
based on the last census in 2010 each
district is drawn to have roughly seven
hundred and ten thousand people in it
now that will change based on the 2020
census but that's how those districts
are drawn right now in the Senate it's
very different each state gets two
senators so California gets two senators
and Montana gets two senators but
California has 40 million people and
Montana has 1 million people living in
the state so in California you have 20
million people per senator whereas in
Montana you have 500 thousand people per
senator Donald Trump has been impeached
by the house each House member voting in
favor or against represents their
710,000 constituents the next step is a
trial in the United States Senate where
senators vote in order to convict Donald
Trump on impeachment you need a
two-thirds vote now depending on which
states senators vote to convict versus
which state senators vote to acquit you
could conceivably have the senators that
represent merely 7% of the American
population decide that Donald Trump is
acquitted even if the Senators
representing 93% of this the country's
population vote to convict there's a
really good piece in The Washington Post
about this by philip bump in the house
you had 53% of House members vote to
impeach and they represent about 53
percent of the American population if
you need 67 senators to vote to convict
you need only 34 to vote to acquit
if 34 vote to acquit there would not be
enough to convict Donald Trump 34
senators means 17 states worth of
Senators
if the Senators come from the smallest
population states those 34 senators who
can decide Donald Trump is acquitted
conceivably represent a population of 24
million people just 7% of the country's
population a lot of senators represent a
whole bunch of land but not that many
people now is that fair I don't know the
answer I mean if you go back to the
history of the United States and why we
have the infrastructure that we do there
are specific reasons why it's deliberate
that every state has the same amount of
Senate representation in this case if 50
percent of the country wants Trump
removed as they do and the Senators
representing just 7% of the population
say now we want them to stay they win is
that disenfranchising in a sense it is
now by the way when I said a lot of
senators represent more land than they
than they do people a lot of Senators in
practice represent mostly corporations
but that's sort of another problem
altogether and not today's discussion
now a lot of these provisions like you
know every state has two senators
regardless of population much like the
electoral college they were put in place
to prevent the so-called tyranny of the
majority which is a worthy goal the
problem is that in practice it has often
backfired
into the tyranny of the minority look at
the electoral college the tyranny of
candidates focusing on arbitrarily small
states and giving small states
disproportionately more power in
deciding who becomes president of the
United States okay it's no longer
tyranny of the majority but the focus is
now arbitrarily something else when it
comes to the Senate
it gives states with very few people
relatively outsized power to make really
important decisions that affect large
swaths of the population impeachment
would of course be something that
affects every American who is president
is a pretty big issue so arguably
there's a problem either way although
it's a different problem in each case
but the mathematical reality is if the
Senators representing 7 percent of the
population in those 34 states decide we
want trump to stay it doesn't matter
what the Senators representing the other
93 percent
those senators representing the 7% get
to decide you tell me whether that's
fair we are wrapping up 2019 on January
1st we will have a major membership
special to kick off 2020 with a bang and
election year often the biggest years of
growth for the show if you are even
mildly interested in supporting the work
that we do and you want to do it at an
obscene disgusting discount go to david
pakman.com sign up for our newsletter
and then on January 1st you will get an
email with the super secret coupon code
allowing you to sign up at a huge huge
discount sign up for the newsletter on
our website let me know what you think
about this tyranny of the majority
versus tyranny of the minority issue by
sending me a tweet at D Pakman I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blankest
books about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli NK is
dot-com /pa que mas